We are here at the Seaspan Shipyards in North Vancouver,...
...announcing the province's support for the national shipbuilding procurement strategy.
The province has been with us from very much the beginning of this process.
To know that their support wasn't just a slap on the back and an applause.
There's something really there.
There is substance.
This support will be in training credits for apprentices. It's wonderful.
That means it's financial support for Seaspan and the shipyard,...
...but it comes when we go out and hire and bring on new apprentices.
So, it's a win-win both for the employees...
...as well as the province and we're very very thankful.